if you had to battle a powerful warlord
what would you do in a battle between
the rich and the poor you'll have to
protect your family from your past
mistakes and you will be forced to watch
everyone you love die in order to
survive the incoming war and change the
world I'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat silico's armies in Arcane part
one this girl is going to watch her
entire family get brutally slaughtered
by here's a tough shit-talking little
girl that has grown up on the wrong side
of town underground in a place called
the lanes a terrifying area filled with
crime where everyone must fight to
survive and she finds out some rich
person has come down to buy some stuff
from her town and she tracks him back to
where he lives in this rich city known
as piltover a city of innovation where
only the most powerful people can live
reaching the top of this building with
her siblings orphans that have grown up
with her one of them asks if what
they're about to do is a good idea and
she tells him to relax because no one
will catch the them and She lays out the
game plan they're going to rob this rich
man's apartment and sell what they can
find staying out of sight they jump from
the roofs of the city and Vai helps her
scared a little sister powder as she
barely keeps up with them they reach the
rich guy's apartment and this eyebrow
guy tries to lock picket glasses guy
over here then notices that the streets
below are crawling with enforcer cops
which means they must be in the right
place if I gets tired of waiting and
busts down the door going inside they
see all these fancy gadgets and vice
suspects that the guy they followed must
be an inventor not knowing what any of
this stuff is they quickly start
collecting everything before anyone
comes home in a meanwhile powder
explores one of the rooms but finds this
strange looking chest opening it she
sees the strange blue crystal balls but
suddenly everyone Hears A Bang at the
door someone is trying to enter acting
quickly they wedge this chair at the
door and block the entrance and quickly
try to escape through the balcony VA
yells out to her sister that they need
to leave shocking powder and she decides
to steal the mystery Crystal balls but
clumsily drops one on the floor on the
way out and it begins to charge up the
owner nearly breaks in as Vice crew runs
out but suddenly the blue crystal ball
hits the wall and the entire apartment
blows up violently shocking everyone
back they all begin to freak out and the
noise alerts all the cops nearby on the
streets parts of the building begins to
crumble and fall onto the city's streets
enforcers and citizens all look up in
Spotify and her siblings in the chaos
the sirens quickly go up and everything
goes to [__] Vise group tries to escape
through the city streets while the
city's enforcers chase after them more
and more of them show up and nearly
overwhelm them VI thinks fast leading
her group down this dark alley and they
quickly open the sewer door and by
aggressively pushes everyone down to
escape alright look I get it that was
crazy but if I was these kids I would
have stolen from the building by using
the principles from sales psychology let
me explain first off your information
you just took information on its face
value from a friend down in the lanes
why would you do that you live in the
lane the dump of the two cities okay
instead I would rely on some
subconscious habits because these kids
don't even know the name of the person
that they stole from what are their
names what's their occupation what are
their daily habits what about the
comings and goings where do they like to
frequent when you have more information
than it only then should you think about
stealing from them and on top of that
don't steal everything at once they
didn't know if this person would be home
or not on top of that all the guards
below them should have made them think a
little bit more about what exactly they
were trying to do maybe pick a different
part of the day when there weren't so
many guards look I get it sometimes we
all want what we can't have especially
when there isn't much of it we need to
use a tactic used in marketing when
Brands put limited time special offers
on their products in order to encourage
customers to feel the urgency to buy
useless crap steal enough things from
our Target to make him have an emotional
reaction is a terrible idea because when
you take the most precious thing from
him then he has more motivation to find
you to hunt you down to get the police
to hunt you down only steal a few things
also bringing along a little kid why the
frick nuts would you do that don't bring
a little snot to your operation lock her
in a room that's what I would do and
then you'll be able to get away Scott
free you're welcome confused on what
just happened the SIM siblings
automatically point the finger at powder
and wonder if she had something to do
with it because she is clumsy as hell
calling her a jinx VI tells them to stop
whining because they just dropped
someone's Rich Penthouse which means
they need to get back to their part of
town now they escape out of this
entrance and quickly cross the bridge
leading out of piltover town barely
Crossing it they managed to escape into
Lane territory escaping the cops for now
but they just run into some lame Thugs
who tell them that the news of a robbery
in piltover has already reached their
side of town and they think they did it
but I think it's a little weird that
they already know since no one in
piltover saw their faces and she tries
to keep things moving this blonde guy's
thugs surround Vice group Blondie Thug
here tells her to share their loot with
him and he'll let them live she agrees
and calmly walks up to him but tricks
him and slams his face in with the
treasure bag handing it off to powder
and her crew begin a straight death
match with these thugs beating the [__]
out of each other as powder watches on
in horror at all the violence this Thug
then targets powder and chases after her
meanwhile Vice crew successfully manages
to beat these thugs up winning the match
blonde guy pulls out a knife but if I
walks right up to him and calls his
bluff making him back away and Retreat
and just then they realize that powder
is missing meanwhile bai's little sister
runs for her life reaching this dead end
she quickly uses her intelligence to
create a small bomb out of scraps
throwing it at the thug but uh nothing
happens now trapped she decides to throw
the bag full of stolen treasure into the
water nearby distracting the thug and
she makes a clean getaway linking back
up with her Squad she tells them the bad
news that she just lost the bag of
treasure eyebrow guy and glasses guy get
annoyed and tell her to stop always
jinxing everything VI tells them to
chill out and tries to comfort her
little sister now finally free from
danger and now no treasure they head
back down into the lanes the most
dangerous part of the city their home in
another part of town this account works
on collecting payment from these
gangsters but they don't want to pay the
full price this nerd gets nervous just
as this big bartender joins them the
gangsters tell him to piss off but he
reveals that this is his bar and these
low lives finally realize who he really
is known as Vander The Hound of the
underground he basically runs the lanes
scared of his badass Sigma reputation
the gangsters apologize and calmly agree
to pay up right as Vander notices his
kids get back and he goes to check in on
them and they try to keep what they did
a secret but Vander reveals that his
connections have already told him what
went down and pilt over and the News
mentioned four kids fleeing the scene
she gets mad and asks them what the hell
were they thinking but if I tries to
defend her group and says that they were
just trying to do a real job for once
and that they had it all planned out but
something went wrong Vander tells the vi
that she has a responsibility to look
after her siblings because they only
have each other and warns them that the
north side of town is off limits he then
tells others to leave and has a heart to
heart with VI he says her siblings all
look up to her and it's her job to watch
them just as it's his job to watch over
everyone down here in the lanes if this
creates problems for piltover then they
will send their terrifying enforcer cops
down here and everybody will likely die
violently agree VI tells them that they
lost the treasure they stole and Vander
says good because this way no one will
be able to tie them to the crime he
tells her to lay low for a while while
he goes to sort things out he rounds up
glasses guy to take him on a trip and
they head to meet with advise informant
the person who gave them the tip about
the guy whose apartment they stole from
in the meantime powder goes to tell Vai
about the blue crystals she found at the
penthouse but over here's eyebrow guy
whining to Vi about how useless powder
is she gets hat and goes to her room
elsewhere Vander finally reaches this
pawn shop and talks to the owner his old
friend and tells the young kid here
Thai's friend an informant named Echo to
give them some privacy now alone the two
adults discuss vander's kids and these
situation this mutton chop guy tells
Vander that they are growing up and that
he can't protect them forever but Vander
tells something concerning bise
mentioned that a group of thugs followed
them today after they left piltover town
and that somehow they knew they were
carrying treasure he suspects that
somebody told the thugs to watch vai's
group but it couldn't have been a cop
especially not from piltover that's
something much more terrifying could be
going on outside glass's Guy waits
outside and talks to Echo the one who
gave them the tip about rich guy and he
tells them that the rich guy came and
paid for everything in gold and because
of this he secretly followed him and
that's how he found out where he lived
and that's when some enforcers are
spotted approaching the area realizing
they've been sent to investigate the
penthouse robbery Echo tells glasses guy
to run before they find him and the
enforcers enter the shop where Vander
and his friend are they tell Vander he
knows everything that went down here and
he thinks that he knows who committed
this crime this young enforcer Cup named
Marcus tries to act tough but the older
cop tells him to take a walk heading out
Echo hides from Marcus and sneaks back
into the building curious he secretly
listens in of the adults in the bar this
older cop named Grayson then gets real
personal with Vander an old friend and
tells him that this time his people
crossed the line and created way too
much noise and piltover and Vander tries
to reassure her that he will deal with
his people but Grayson says it's too
late the penthouse they destroyed
belonged to one of the most powerful
families in piltover leaving him a phone
she says to call her if he changes his
mind meanwhile via goes to check on
powder but she reveals that she heard
everything and feels really sad Thai
tries to comfort her and tells her that
she's she's not a fighter but a genius
inventor taking her to their rooftop she
tells her stories of their siblings and
how they've all made mistakes in the
past but no matter what they must always
stick together powder then pulls out her
blue crystal balls that she took from
the rich guy's apartment but if I think
some we probably shouldn't tell about
this for now and that was her biggest
mistake oh my gosh if I was her I would
not do that I would have saved us all
the long-term Agony by employing some
very nasty poverty-inducing
psychological warfare on her mind in
order to permanently further destroy
powder's childhood innocence let me
explain Vander here is a reformed badass
and is the basic president of the lanes
of this rather interesting dumpster fire
of a garbage heap but him being
influential means that he's got to have
a lot of enemies that might try to take
him down maybe help the guy out and tell
your daddy about the freaking crystal
blue Powder balls because wild world
would you not do that powder is a
freaking child who's unreliable yeah she
can invent stuff but they're not
consistent and also powder she's super
clumsy and is always getting into
trouble and it makes you wonder why Bai
didn't confiscate those tiny little
crystal blue balls in the first place
save yourself a potential Nightmare and
when this object came from their
Target's apartment the same Target had a
bunch of wild untested experiments and a
bunch of weird alien crap and that same
apartment blew up if stuff like that
happened it might make me think that Vai
really isn't that good of a sister I
would have put my freaking little foot
down and would have told off powder and
told her that hey you're a freaking
liability you're gonna get us all killed
you need to keep your butt here and stay
here so we can all live and that you are
dead weight because if powder doesn't
start listening to what if I is saying
she's gonna get them all killed
elsewhere down in this dark evil lair
the Blondie Thug from earlier Deckard
gets tortured by this group of
mysterious criminals they warn him that
he was only supposed to watch fi's group
and to not interfere with them because
now Vander is asking questions about it
if they aren't careful he will find out
what's really going on this man says
they can't afford to have this habit
scared and desperate blonde guy tells
them that vanter's kids are the ones who
caused the explosion in the city
shocking these men this one leader
thinks that his old friend of Ander is
now in trouble with piltover and
this changes everything he announces to
his men that they must now speed up
their timeline and his henchmen show him
what Horrors they've been working on
setting up a live experiment right in
front of him they watched this cat
inside of this cage with a rat scared
the rat drinks from this bottle filled
with a mysterious pink potion and very
quickly it transforms into a huge
mutated monster and it instantly
Slaughters this cat making this boss
happy as hell and tells him that in
order to begin their evil plans they
must first test this potion on a live
Human oh he'll work blonde guy the next
day in piltover town the inventor whose
apartment got stolen gets interrogated
by the police named Jace Grayson here
finds out that he is a student at the
city's most prestigious Science school
and whose family was saved by a
mysterious wizard when he was a kid but
as she delivers him some bad news and
says they discovered a ton of illegal
items in his apartment that he doesn't
have permits for this mysterious man
close by overhears him and reveals that
he is the assistant to the dean of the
school Chase goes to who is also the
head of the council he's been sent by
the powerful Dean to remove any magic
related items here that could be
dangerous Grayson that informs Jace the
worst news of all he must be taken to
jail and he will be investigated by the
magic Council and they drag him away
later he gets a visit from someone
special the dean of the school and the
head of the magic Council Professor
Heimerdinger but we'll call him little
professor H he said that Jace reminds
him of himself but warned him that great
science my boy must never put anybody in
danger and blah blah blah blah blah
Chase tries to convince him that he's
found a way to harness magic through
science but he needs more experiments to
really figure it out this makes
professor H nervous as hell and warns
him that the magic of Arcane is
dangerous it's a force of Nature and one
that Humanity shouldn't control alright
look we're getting into some serious
shite but if I was just I would maybe
consider the actions of humanity over
the last 3 000 years I would maybe
compare them to the guy who invented the
now standard car assembly line
production let me explain despite what
people tell you Society deep down his
rather selfish a lot from the one we
were babies to toddlers stealing from
each other and lying right kindness and
honesty is a learned habit according to
the anthropocene research group a
geoscience based research team dedicated
to investigating the impacts of humanity
and what they have on the planet they've
officially declared we now live in a
period of History where our impact
hacked on the Earth has now begun to
show and is beginning to reach its
limits ever since Humanity started
growing big enough to become a threat to
the world our need to be the main
character in this story proves why
professor H worrying about magic and
putting in the wrong hands makes perfect
sense especially when you look at our
history of the nature in the first place
okay for example in 1927 when Henry Ford
wanted to create his own supply of
rubber down in the Amazon rainforest he
basically tried to create an American
town down here among the people that
didn't want to be Americanized and tried
to plant trees that couldn't actually be
grown in the Amazon rainforest this
project named fordlandia was a huge
freaking mess and this only made Ford
more determined to tame the men of this
jungle as well and it resulted in a huge
disaster for everybody all because of
one man's ego trying to play God despite
for man's amazing potential for
Innovation and the potential good that
magic could have due to Humanity's
innate selfish shitty meme attitude I
would have been way more cautious about
developing this sort of technology in
the first place especially if a war
happened because of the material or
matter they were working on I.E magic
because it could very well cause the
destruction of the world it almost did
before for a guy with a lot of books and
some brains he's not that smart
professor H reveals to Jace that while
he 24 in all of his great wisdom might
want to listen to the 307 year old
Headmaster because he was alive when the
city of piltover was built professor H
warns him that some science is better
left unsolved and this one is one of
them he then gives Jace The Game Plan of
what to say when he meets the council at
his trial because he should own up to
his mistakes not mention anything about
magic because saying all of this
destruction was because of magic will
only freak everyone out and if he does
this then they might get a little slap
on the wrist and go free meanwhile via
and her siblings try to lay low from the
cops but then discover that several
squads of them have started to move
through the lanes and then they overhear
one of them interrogating a citizen they
ask of this low life if they know who
committed that explosion but this dude
tells them to go fudge themselves and
then he gets thrown through this window
right to revise family is instantly
getting spotted by the enforcers they
come inside and everybody holds their
breath they try to play it cool as the
place gets searched one of them walks up
to power but that's when Vai looks at
powder staring at her and she sees what
she has in her pocket
it's horrifying she is still carrying
the blue crystal energy boss but that's
when Vai signals glasses guy to create a
distraction shutting down the power all
the kids quickly make a break for it
running out of the back the gang quickly
gets cornered but then sees Echo pop out
from nowhere to save them dropping them
this ladder they escape by the Skin of
Their Teeth Vitale's powder that she
needs to hide those crystals now
elsewhere back and pilot over this
counselor named melamar Dara sneakily
plans how to gain more power within the
council she complains to her Minions
that they need to discover and find
something that will put this city back
on the map again and make her stand out
from the council since she is seen as
the weakest of them her assistant throws
out some wild ideas and oh mentions that
there is a trial going on right now for
a man named Jace meanwhile back in the
lanes Founder's people are getting angry
at what's been going on too many cops
have been showing up and have gotten
into their businesses and lives are
getting ruined they think they should
retaliate but Vander reminds them that
it's peace time right now between the
rich and the poor City and that they
shouldn't disrupt the delicate balance
he reminds them they try this year's ago
and was a complete bloodbath he begs his
people to listen to him and tells them
that he's doing this to protect them
this one lady named savika tells Vander
that he's changed and he is no longer
the bloodthirsty animal he once was and
he's grown weak Vine her siblings listen
in and also wonder why Vander doesn't
want to fight but they find out from
Echo that he overheard that Vander made
a deal with the piltover police the next
day the trial of Jace begins and he
shows up to meet the Council of piltover
the most powerful people gather around
including Mel and his Caitlyn's mother
her and Professor 8 vouch for Jace and
he falls exactly what the professor H
tells him to say and doesn't say zip
zilchinata about any magic but this
backfires because now the council thinks
that Jace was just messing around with
dangerous equipment for no reason and
now think he's not fit to live in this
city anymore desperate Jace blurts out
his real reason for creating the most
dangerous experiment and mentions the
use of magic tells them the most insane
thing ever he was trying to artificially
create Magic through science shocking
everyone body and disappointing
professor H this one council member
warns him that Arcane magic is something
you are born with and cannot be created
but Jace tells them that magic can be
used for good and that they should take
a chance but professor H tells him to
shut it because he doesn't know what's
at stake now that everything's out on
the table professor H reveals to Jace
and reminds the rest of the council
members why they should be so afraid of
what Jace has just discovered he was
alive during the Great War and saw how
destructive Arcane magic was and how it
corrupted the minds of anybody who
wielded it piltover was founded to
escape the destruction that evil wizards
created all those centuries ago and must
be protected from this the council
agrees with him and tells Jace that
trying to make magic accessible to the
common people is too risky and because
of this he must be banished at once but
then Jace's mother then interrupts the
proceedings and tells them that her son
is not in his right mind and chases an
Impossible Dream to change the world her
tears make professor H have a heart and
he said that he can understand Jace's
dream his enthusiasm and saves him by
convincing the council to expel him from
his Academy and to go back into the care
of his parents later Jace's mom tells
her son that he should be grateful that
he got let off as easily as he did she
warns him that magic saved their lives
once years ago but he should stop
obsessing over it it'll ruin his life
pissed off Jay says he could have
convinced the council if she stuck to
his side and tells her that if she won't
support him he will find someone else
who will okay this has turned into an
absolute [__] show I would even predict
everything that happened right here
Years Ago by just focusing on the third
goal of the scientific method let me
explain Jace here is one of the youngest
brightest and most handsome people in
all of the city at least that's what we
see from the show so because of this it
makes sense why he's been acting way
more like a scientist in training than
an actual scientist because here's the
thing inside the first steps is to
analyze and answer researched based
questions and is to go through something
known as the scientific method where
scientists will first make observations
about something and then from there
researching what is already known about
the topic that they are studying to come
up with a theoretical hypothesis in
order to answer their question and in
this case Jay is studying to be a
scientist meant that he should have
expected major pushback when he revealed
his findings to a city that is terrified
of anything related to magic one of the
first three goals of the scientific
method is one understanding which Jace
already knew a lot about magic and also
nothing about magic at the same time too
prediction where will this discovery
lead to one of the potential
ramifications which Jace already stated
and three most importantly control for
scientists to be able to understand
their subject matter so much that they
are able to manipulate the matter in
whichever way they choose but again
Chase revealing what he was working on
may have been his only way to save
himself but in reality he should have
been way more conscious about studying
how to control magic and he should have
understood that proving that he could
control magic at all would have taken
more than just one man to solve his
problem meanwhile back in Professor H's
study he discusses with his assistant
about Jace's magic Theory the assistant
tries to convince him that Chase's
Innovation could be watched over by him
and this would allow them to see if Jace
is really onto something but professor H
dismisses him and orders him to burn
Jace's study and all of his work not
really realizing that his assistant has
other plans and he secretly swipes one
of Chase's Diaries elsewhere the Council
of hilltover calls Grayson and her
partner Marcus to give them an update on
their investigation but she tells them
that her police still haven't found the
culprits concerned the council warns her
that because magic was involved the
public is getting scared and now
everybody's starting to get worried
about if somebody is running around wild
with magic powers the robbers must be
captured soon or else Grayson will be in
huge trouble a little later Grayson's
younger partner Marcus gets a tip to
meet with a strange man who says he can
help him and his partner with the
investigation not revealing his identity
he and Marcus make a deal in exchange to
help him find the penthouse culprits he
then uses this tip to take the
investigation into his own hands taking
some police back up men to meet Vander
entering This Bar Marcus directly tells
him that he knows this guy knows the
culprits and asks where the four kids
are he signals for his men to search the
place Vander quickly sends an alert to
his kids downstairs telling them that
trouble is coming quickly hiding this
cop enters the room and finds it empty
not realizing that just above him powder
is holding on to dear life back upstairs
Marcus asks for a drink while he waits
and tells Vander that he recently ran
into one of his old Friends and says
that he knows that Vander used to be a
ruthless criminal Warrior shocking
bander he realizes who Marcus met up
with and this changes everything just
below the cop gives up looking for the
kids and leaves the room right before
powder Falls apparently he heads back
upstairs and reports that he found
nothing pissing off Marcus and they
leave Marcus warns everyone that he's
going to bury all of them soon letting
out a sigh of relief Factor quickly goes
to check in on his kids and VI gives him
a dose of reality he can't help them
anymore and soon they will get caught
unless they fight back Panther hesitates
and VI warns him and says that if he
says no they will fight without him at
the end of his ropes Vander takes VI to
this bridge outside of their home to
show her why he's trying to keep the
peace with the cops from piltover he
reveals that he was once angry like her
and led their people across this bridge
years ago wanting to change the power
imbalance his people tried to fight the
rich but got slaughtered and because of
his actions via's parents got killed he
warns her that Revenge will cost her the
people she loves he finally tells her
that he doesn't know what to do when the
enforcers come back but they'll they'll
figure it out back at Jace's apartment
with no future he prepares to have a
long drop and sudden stop but then gets
interrupted by Professor H's assistant
he tells him that he likes what he's
trying to do and hands him one of his
experiments from earlier that he stole
from the academy Vault one of his blue
crystal energy balls and he introduces
himself as Victor and tells him that he
doesn't want to be an assistant forever
and wants to partner up with Jace to
help him with his experiment Jay says
that he can't do anything without his
equipment but that's when Victor reveals
that he knows where his equipment is
being held and since he is the assistant
to the Headmaster he has the keys to the
room and the two agree to become
Partners a little later Marcus reaches
back to Police Headquarters and gets in
trouble with Grayson for going down into
the lanes without permission she calls
him a fool and tells him that he doesn't
realize what he's just done but then a
message arrives later that night Vander
rushes back home storming and he tells
VI something is going down and they need
to hide he shoves her down to this
basement right as these Cops show up
prepared to arrest someone and Grayson
is with them and gives him one last out
telling him that she now has no choice
he is not the one they want give her the
girl telling him that if he goes to
prison to cover for her everything that
he's worked for down the lanes will fall
apart but Vander says this is the only
way pilotor wants their pound of Flesh
and the cops lead the way outside of the
bar taking Vander with them downstairs
by bangs on the door and yells out to
Vander but that's when she hears a
violent commotion outside through this
window and suddenly streaks of blood
Paints the window blinding her vision
and Vander and the survivors outside
stare in confused shock and what just
happened they see something has just
brutally slaughtered all of the cops
here including Grayson then they spot a
familiar face approaching them down the
distance recognizing him and modern chop
gets angry begins to charge at the man
Vander tries to stop him but he gets
slaughtered as well by this unknown
mutant creature Marcus Angley calls out
to this man named silco and tells him
that this wasn't part of the deal but
Silko says deals change this mutant
creature approaches Vander and knocks
him out all the while is VI watches and
get taken away through a Blood Stained
window she finally manages to break out
and Echo tells her that he knows where
they took Vander down into the worst
part of town silco reaches his operating
base with Vander telling him that his
methods may be extreme but explains that
sometimes base violence is necessary for
change because the rich people of
piltover won't listen to any other way
Vander warns him that his evil Army of
mutants won't be able to stop them but
silco tells him that he doesn't need to
win he just needs to scare them so that
no rich person will ever set foot
underground again and they can rule this
underground city without any Authority
he tells Vander that he's disappointed
in him they were friends once they once
wanted the same thing for the lanes he
then announces that after years of
experimentation they finally have the
upper hand against them revealing the
this new potion called Shimmer with this
they can finally achieve their dream of
ruling the city back in piltover Victor
and Jace managed to sneak into the
council's store but get caught by one of
the council members Mel with Nothing
Left to Lose Jace begs her to believe in
him and that his invention Works Victor
quickly chimes in to tell her that they
figured out how to stabilize it
desperate for some success Mel gives
them one chance to prove their theory
for her as she covers for them while
they get back to work trying to
stabilize the crystal they suddenly set
off a whole heck of a lot of lights in
the room but some of the soldiers
outside get alerted now on the clock
they quickly set off their magic just as
their experiment freaks out and they
barely managed to harness the power of
magic and who it was close the now
alerted guards reached the room and bust
down the door along with professor H but
everyone sees that this time the boys
have actually done it
Mel joins in and tells them that because
of their recent discovery perhaps now
the magic Council will now have to
decide that maybe they should Usher in a
new age of magic but Jace corrects her
and says not magic hextech in the
meantime Bai finally reaches her
siblings and tells them what just
happened telling everybody to suit up to
go save fan powder tries to join in but
Vai tells her it's too dangerous
especially for her and she must stay
behind but of course she doesn't listen
and follows after them she threw her
toys on the floor and suddenly came up
with a terrifying idea and absolutely
horrific idea Thai's group finally
arrives at silco's location thanks to
Echo and try to break Vander out but
it's a trap silco suddenly enters and
brings his men in to stop them and
everybody gets ready for a death match
VI whips out vander's old fighting
gloves from back in the day and this big
tattooed hulking cue ball of a man tries
to attack her but she smacks him down
and takes him out as she tries to keep
silko's minions busy while her groups
work on freeing bender and silkel smiles
and whips out another pink potion giving
it to blonde guy from earlier and he
turns into horrified monster once more
Bai tries to attack it but he easily
grabs her and throws her down nearby
powder not listening to her sister
reaches the warehouse and sneaks up onto
the roof she sees her sister through
this window and sees by like her and her
family in this room and sees the monster
trying to break down the door knowing
it's only a matter of time until this
mutant breaks in she takes out her
electric energy balls and puts one of
them into her toys winding it up she
carefully sets it down and sends it
towards the mutant monster and begins
backing banging banging sending shock
waves and then finally it explodes
sending a massive wave of energy around
everybody instantly killing glass
disguise and eyebrow guy powder didn't
save anyone this is bad look if I was
them I would have used the unique
architecture of this place I mean look
at it this bad guy's headquarters with
its shutter doors I would have used that
way better in order to be able to help
Vander escape and everybody stay alive
let me explain why yet again proved how
she is a horrible leader it seems like
she never takes into account powder's
manic personality and her inability to
stay still sounds like to me like
powder's got some sort of form of ADHD
because look at powder she shows signs
of being unable to sit still unable to
concentrate on a task given to her and
clearly acted without thinking to the
point that she was given the nickname
Jinx powder acts on impulse without
thinking that's a huge trait that VI
should have spotted earlier so by taking
into account powder's craziness I would
have locked her up or sedated her put
together some sort of cocktail that's
the equivalent of CBD oil maybe some
lavender maybe some ashwagandha mellow
this girl out and lock her up and put
her away because then you don't have a
potential Loose Cannon happening also
when doing this plan I would not have
rushed over to go save Vander with just
my crew look Vander is an important
influential person sounds like the most
important person in the lanes I'm sure
that there's some people sympathetic to
him that like him that like his
leadership maybe go find them and have
them come help you because then you
would have had extra help and then don't
rush in new laid on the roof before
entering him from that vantage point you
can look at the windows and have a good
view of the whole inside of the building
one of the signs commonly found in most
of Transportation of goods into and out
of buildings are shutter doors when
showing up on the roof of this Warehouse
I would have first noted that for a bad
guy headquarters security is awfully
light which is super suspicious to begin
with and due to the fact that we don't
know what we're up against I would have
shown up with all the people that I
brought with me and have stationed some
of them outside of the warehouse that
way we have some sort of backup being
able to come in and help us out and on
top of that we need some sort of mobile
ride more than just our feet be able to
drive right through the large roller
shutter door entrances which then would
have allowed us to park our getaway
vehicle or get away whatever closer to
where Vander was being held and be able
to make for a much easier mode of
transportation but yet again is a
horrible leader a horrible planner and
that is why Vander never trusted her to
pull any jobs for him personally after
in the rubble Vander wakes up somehow
not dead and sees his kids dead and wide
badly injured Furious and in a rage he
easily kills soco's surviving henchmen
and attacks the mutant trying to reach
silco but he gets fatally stabbed in the
back by him pushing him off of this
bridge bones broken organs punctured and
about to die Vander drinks one of
silco's Shimmer potions and transforms
into a horrible monster himself getting
up he easily kills blonde guy and
directs VI to get out of here the potion
now taking over his mind he spots silco
and tries to get him again but realizes
that he needs to help if I escape
directing his attention to her he
quickly gets her out of the building
before the whole thing explodes and on
the street Vander tells Vai to watch
over powder and he finally kicks the
bucket and just then powder finds VI and
happily tells her that her monkey bomb
works it worked she saved everybody but
that's when she sees Bender dead and Vai
realizes that she is the one responsible
for all of the deaths and her eyes go
cold powder starts crying and
desperately says but she only wanted to
help she didn't mean this and she begs
Vibe please believe me please believe me
but VI grabs her and tells her that she
never listens and that she is a jinx and
shoves her away and Via leaves the scene
as powder begs her screams for her to
not leave her now all alone powder
breaks down as a badly injured silco
shows up with his men ready to kill her
if I sees this in the distance and tries
to go back and rescue her but gets
grabbed by Marcus and tells her that if
she goes there she'll die and he knocks
her out with a sleeping drug and drags
her into the shadows silco and his men
then decide to spare powder and powder
hugs him sharking silco and she says
that VI left her and isn't her sister
anymore seeing his once old friend
Vander dead in front of him he decides
to adopt her and tells her that they
will soon pay he will soon all of them
pay what do you guys think about the
video let us know what you like about it
and what you didn't like it don't forget
to like subscribe leave a comment down
below and as always don't forget to
check out our how to be playlist